we've got we've got Sebastian Maniscalco
powerhouse he's the powerhouse wrote a
book I don't know how much of a reader
the man is it's not like when I see him
it's not like dude have you read the new
Nassim Taleb book on now but he'll write
a book okay well I'll write a book and
the difference between a man who writes
books and comes up with original ideas
and a guy who regurgitate she's read
there's also a guy who's killing it in
the comedy game we don't have time to
read books I don't have a lot of time
he's busy creating his own history it's
Sebastian in the house Sebastian the
house
thanks for having me no thank you for
having making the time couple things
right off the bat the last book I read
or actually started in 2015 was the
autobiography of Andre Agassi I've read
it odd life life and my mom I think to
page 201 so that's I'm still trying to
crank that out I know you're a big
reader I don't know if you really dabble
that's all yeah you like to read it's a
lot I call them TED Talks from TED talk
yes well there cuz it cuz there's doing
smart talk and then like we were talking
about this for me and Hunter on the
podcast you're gonna have a lot of smart
talk and you can always find smart talk
people talking about what the problems
are but is there a solution like well
you know I talk to these really smart
people I'm like I got you I get all the
problems do you have a solution like a
workable one that that I can actually
apply and that's the riddle why vials
well whatever the problems are right
come come if you're gonna look if you go
to one person and solve all your
problems you [ __ ] what I'm saying there
there are problems it's like emigrate
illegal immigration or gun control
whatever it is they you know what is
your solution what are you actually
gonna do and you have all the answers I
do and it's in the book and why'd you
decide to write it because it's
intimidating writing a book right it is
I didn't set out to do this when I
started my career I didn't think I was
going to write a book but three or four
years ago my managers like yeah you know
you should you should write a book and
I'm like I don't know if I have a real
story to tell I mean there was no
adversity or you know like I always
thought people that wrote books had like
a big thing that happened
overcame cancer they came back from war
another helping other veteran I'm I
don't really have a story but then I
said diving back into my career started
looking at the funny things that kind of
happened to me along the way and the ups
and downs of being a stand-up comedian
and I'm like oh yeah we could get into
this so it took it took a while took
about three years to write and it's it's
gettin it's gettin good good feedback
you know but you have a story though
because you say like people with cancer
or like professional athletes write
books but with your story I feel like
more people can relate to what you're
doing and your journey then someone you
know LeBron James or Michael Jordan or
felt something like that yeah well as a
witness here we'll just go real quick
because just going through your journey
some of the jobs you've had to get to
this point yeah like whenever I met your
name I was talking we rods in st. Louis
man and I meant to reach out to you I
don't know you that well I don't want
you I don't wanna come off like I was
gonna send me a dick pic or some in your
DMS but I was in st. lino shut up but
hey man come on the podcast dick dousche
anyways on a block of wood no pressure
no pressure but if you want to come hold
an arch and like alright let me you
fighting sorry this gonna be a nice
thing I was gonna say but you ruined
that I was in st. Louis man there's some
rough crap a great town some rough grass
stuff like that and me and ro were
talking about getting this inspired and
stuff like that I was I was I going like
these benders of comics you know cuz I'm
obsessed with comedy so I go on these
benders I went I went down the path of
Sebastian I was watching all that and
then I I told a tech throwing I'm Akay
Sebastian's a good guy honey saqib and
pious like I don't know that well and
Roman said the best things about you so
nice and then I was listening on Maron
and your time about these jobs you're
having I was like why so many more
people can relate to that
oh yeah cuz when you talk cuz everyone
goes oh I want to make in Hollywood
whether it's a comedian actor but then
what do you really work as a witness to
his journey like you always had that
working-class Italian work ethic you
would just show up and you do your
[ __ ] work we would be in Vegas you'd
show up
you never saw Sebastian out
partying drinking girls he was just he
show up like a gentleman well-dressed
don't be surprised if he's got cufflinks
shoes abolished he'd get up there crush
a room about 1,500 people and then
[ __ ] leave you come in and do your
job and I think you were a waiter at
Susan's for how many years seven years
but that one was nice compared to some
of the other stuff yeah early on it was
rough I was selling satellite dishes in
the ghetto time what what's your pitch
cuz you're such a bubbly guy this is
what I did it was at the Baldwin Hills
Mall on Crenshaw Martin Luther King
Drive that's a good area all right and
fit in there
oh I fit right in and I had a kiosk and
I was selling Dish Network subscriptions
out of a kiosk and I would do since it
was an urban type of mall black black it
was a blackish black dog good god laughs
yeah so I would put Michael Jackson on
because IV yard the Michael Jackson my
25-year reunion a Motown or whatever
your your bait was Michael Michael
Jackson so much this the seventies er
this was in 2001 2002 and I had about 85
people around the kiosk just emailing us
and no one buying dishes just dancing so
yeah I did that for a while that's a
good time but no sales or sales
Sebastian we love you mate you bring in
a crowd but she would sold one goddamn
dish man no dishes sold it was bad I
gotta get into bad financial that after
doing that and I did I did that's funny
how you'll see certain segments of the
population certain girls have no qualms
about just breaking out in advance
he's a guy had I was a bus stopping this
it was more black mostly black women and
his dude shows up with a [ __ ] boom
box on a bike
and every one of the women circling yeah
they started dancing and they were all
dancing here I was like this is [ __ ]
fantastic it's the craziest lots man so
they were all busting a move how many
dishes did you sell not a wanna oh yeah
I would sell it was a hundred bucks I
got four per dish
yeah yeah I thought like okay and I'll
sell five him maybe five a day it's not
that hard everybody needs cable or some
type of entertainment in their home but
it was a really tough sell I mean also
when I did sell one they thought I was
customer service so they would call me
in the dumbass I am I would put my home
line on the hard not because I didn't
want to run up my minutes this is what
minutes and cellphones were big yeah
so I didn't I didn't have enough money
to like take the minute so I'm like give
him my home line but my office so I
would get a call at 3 o'clock in the
morning and they'd be like yeah what
what channel is CNN I'm like it's 200
remote so I'm like fielding customer
service calls
not dime one so yeah those are the early
on I was working it used to be Captain
Morgan at bars I used to walk in you
were dressed like a pirate a pirate I
didn't come in as a pirate I had my
outfit in my bag yeah and I would ask to
borrow an or excuse me was there a place
that could set up I was gonna pass out
shots and with the goods you have
Captain Morgan girls too no just me oh
that's not suppressing at all yeah no
girls no nothing I would walk into like
a biker bar and there you know peanuts
and beer and I would come out of the
bathroom and be like oh it's actually a
very good plan I kill myself I'll cut my
own throat I did it girls like I work
for captain Morgan's like god that's
that's a big time job and she was one of
the captain working girls I guess they
upped your pay or the the whole kind of
marketing plan cuz I came in she had
some dude some poor soul playing Captain
Morgan they had he was flocked by four
girls on each side oh yeah another still
until this is before they had a budget
for fat girl so I just went in solo so
we're doing open mics at this point too
yeah I started in 1998 and did open mics
all throughout Los Angeles and my first
one was at Highland Grounds what was the
first joke you ever wrote that killed uh
killed was probably my Ross but was the
best joke I haven't read the Ross for
let Dress for Less which seemed to be
one of the most popular bits I had a
ring on it thanks and you thrall and
[ __ ] well is throwing [ __ ] this not like
the place looks like downtown Beirut and
the [ __ ] all over the floor and you know
you're in housewares you're looking and
you find a pair of jeans you know it's
just nothing's in the right place over
here so uh yeah that was kind of my
signature bit for a while and then you
know just it took a while seven eight
years you know this [ __ ] I mean it takes
a bit to kind of get your feet wet and
start developing a fanbase and each year
it kind of gradually got better I'm
sorry my phone's on you did it the right
way right i mean it's it's almost like i
don't know to be really like it's one
thing to get popular to be really good
at anything it's just gonna take a long
time yeah i had no TV no TV exposure and
a film exposure no nothing it was just
all i knew how to do with stand-up
comedy so I just kept going out going to
these clubs I would go back the next
year you know and more people would come
meet-and-greet and I'm selling my DVDs
and I didn't know anybody I just like I
just want to do stand-up comedy and I
want to do it every night and I want to
get better and better and at it and I'm
still doing that same that same
mentality is still in my head of going
out there and learning every night and
that was the traditional path especially
back then that's the way I think most
people did it and then what did you get
a big break where some big comic was
about you to feature open up former Dice
Clay I went on the road with him for two
years so that really
yeah I did two years with dice learned a
lot from him playing bigger rooms to
three thousand seat theaters and he
still crushes doesn't he yeah I mean
let's just two thousand again this is
2002 2003 2004 I went out and you know
he asked me to do the Stardust Hotel
with him a Wayne Newton Theatre first
time doing anything quite that big but I
learned a lot from dice off stage as
well because here's a guy who you know
did all these arenas he was at the top
of his game and then you know he came
off the mountain for a little bit and
he's all he's always told me he wanted
to get back to doing arenas and you know
TV film acting and and here is it's not
shown now so he's doing really nice work
acting and so I I just learn like when I
don't talk much around people I'm not a
talker I like to listen so when you go
out with me I'm not like the guy who's
gonna be the center of attention
especially if I'm around people who know
more than I do I shut the [ __ ] up yeah I
don't I don't I don't talk I'd rather
listen to people rather than me talk way
to go it's a great course oh for sure
yeah that's for damn sure I mean you're
generally a talk he likes to do that
yeah I've always been yeah the guy who's
talking the whole time yeah but it's
it's fine I'm not saying that you know
but you're you're an opportunity here
you're entertaining while you talk
you're not like it's not forced now some
guys are just a little force with their
you know the way they do it but you're
actually really really entertaining to
listen to so I don't I don't mind she
was silly but yeah would would dice
would he tell you about his failure so
he could learn from her was at all
positive the things well he bailed on
stage because his crowd was really
really rough one night and I was
supposed to do 15 minutes I bailed at
11:00 because the crowd was yelling at
me and I froze I didn't know what to do
I was like alright guys see up and he
was angry he was like you know I'm
expecting you to do 15 minutes and
you're getting off at 11 I'm getting my
when you come off four minutes early I
gotta go on and I might not be right you
got to do the time I don't care what
these people are doing out there you
cannot let them take control so these
lessons that I was learning as a young
comedian from a guy who's been there
done that was very valuable moving
forward so I tend to like really really
kind of take it in and Vince Vaughn took
me then this Vince Vaughn Wild West
comedy show in 2005 and I learned press
from him this guy would get up at 5:30 6
o'clock in the morning and he would be
doing 5 6 radio shows right in a row
he'd be walking around the parking lot
on the phone
promoting the show because the the Vince
Vaughn Wild West comedy show was all
like spur of the moment he had to sell
tickets because people really didn't
know the show was coming to pound three
four days crises so this guy's doing all
this press so you know I don't know you
probably get it when you go to these
clubs hey sorry he had to get up this
early to come in I'm like sorry it's
part of the yeah you know let's say you
got to get up to sell tickets I don't
never understood comedians like bitching
and complaining yeah but they could I
get up 5:30 in the morning to sell
tickets to make money yeah show at their
show yeah and but exactly that that's a
help you sell the [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah so
I saw that from Vince Vaughn I'm like
that's what it takes to sell tickets so
along the way just kind of pick in these
little these little nuggets of
information from the people who were
successful I'm like okay you know this
is what I kind of have to do and I think
also comedy is something that is such a
meritocracy but it's also like something
that you when you come into a town
you're competing with a lot of other
things so so you know like I did
Huntsville this weekend and Bama and we
had it has a real rivalry with is maybe
Georgia
Robert Robert and they had a gymnastics
meet
well yeah 20,000 people Jesus 20,000
people showed up and it for the weekend
it was like they were just going to that
anything out BAM I was like what's going
on here they go there's a Bama you know
so you're competing with everything
different crowd but yeah especially it
depends really out like Vegas is a
the nightmares I mean it's literally
they said that I mean there are some
that they don't give a [ __ ] run in
shower and see Celine Dion you know it's
like yeah and Michael Jackson's up
Street yeah a hologram but you know I'm
saying but she's not sure that's a
pretty good show I heard it's good yeah
yeah I heard sounds a hologram I thought
Michael Jackson came I thought it would
no I heard it too like the best show I
thought sorry sir you're kidding room
yeah that is this no you gotta check it
out what's it look like Michael Jackson
hologram the hologram out of the circus
Anna what's the the hotel next minute
like really real or sight well not only
the hologram on this show they got an
Asian guy who dances better than Michael
Jackson how dare you sir is that it
that's it hologram but but I mean
watching it here is yeah you know I have
to say about Ellen DeGeneres
I'd forgotten about this I may be my
biggest influence comedic Lee
I'm not joking really Ellen when she was
doing comedy everyone says she was like
well all-time great
I did see I'm too young how's Ted young
and you guys she for me I know it from
the Ellen show knows it go there she is
watch her old Stan he's a mind blowing
it was like it was my boy but Michael
Jackson big influence on me as well as
for his physical and his I like to be
very physical on stage and watching him
doing doing quick noon all done on stage
really kind of influenced me in in my
calm in comedy because I'm not a guy to
kind of just sit behind a microphone and
tell jokes as you know as you are very
kind of you guys are super Anna yes so
you all you did some private dancing in
college well I mean I talked about that
on the podcast I think you're also like
this day and age Irwin goes man if
you're not if you're not on Netflix
you're not doing anything and
and every literally if I'm in a circle
of comedians agents anywhere in
Hollywood when someone goes on Netflix
they go nope Sebastian Showtime well
this is the thing all of them say la I'm
telling you all go look what Showtime
did for Sebastian
yeah Showtime was very very critical
when I was doing and Netflix is great
it's it's a juggernaut the honker they
got a lot of a lot of subscribers but
Showtime for me really pinpointed my
audience it was an audience that was a
little bit skewed a little bit older
they had disposable income they were you
know families and and they had some
money to come out and buy a premium
ticket so I got a lot of people from
Showtime and at the time
Netflix used to take your comedy special
in a second window so it would live on
Showtime for two years and then it would
go to Netflix so he got kind of like the
best of both worlds what Netflix is not
really doing that anymore they're
producing their own originals and and
and well you do your next special
Showtime inept I don't know I don't know
we're shooting at April 21st and at
Radio City Music calling all their
cities so the nominees on the list from
four of eight the blaster business out
there that's why we brought you we need
Aloe yes we saw the mighty your major
we're doing just fine but still you can
always use more money how's your life
changing out of your you have servants
obviously okay
well came in a helicopter that's cool
yeah it's it's outside boys a Porsche
guy I know just like you well aware it's
my wife's
yeah well that's his wife's like I Drive
a scooter I'm like it I have a Vespa
really yeah I was a little colder driver
today so I don't [ __ ] drive it on the
highway for god no no no I would drive
that on the side streets I don't drive
anything either and you have kids right
I have one little daughter ten months
old and you know the whole the whole the
game changes one that when the kids
cough course and
and you know my wife and I take the
daughter on the road I like taking my
wife on the road yeah we she's been to
ten cities already we just went to
Chicago she came to Toronto with me
what do you stay you stay at a hotel you
stay at hotels yeah yes I don't just buy
a house there in the back you know I
might buy an apartment and just leave it
I got him empty apartments everywhere
and your wife been with you this whole
journey how long have you been you know
we've been together nine years so she
was kind of she came on when I was
starting to cook a little bit doing
headlining shows and selling him out she
wasn't there during struggle City no no
but she was there
shortly after I mm yeah yeah yeah yeah
we met through a mutual friend actually
we met through at the trainer yeah yeah
I did add some moisture amazing that
tell you about this last time sure yeah
I had a baby oil start the kids been
great the the career you know as you
grow you start you know having to hire
some people to kind of help you out on
the road which is something that you
know I was doing all this stuff myself I
would go to the whatever the venue I
would do my own press I would sell my
own DVDs no one told me to wake up you
got these people that they are going
with like a large entourage of people
which I kind of understand but you know
the why I run my little little little
lien crew you know just a tour manager
and now I got my buddy that signed that
that used to train my wife and I he
comes out to kind of keep me in line in
regards to my my weight and all that
stuff because I really kind of on the
road it's tough it was tough I can't
even a little lot of weight on the road
not for me but I am just well that's
what I'm trying to achieve a you likely
gift it doesn't guys like us Sebastian
you know hey man stop trying to be all
like buddy-buddy with him well I'm just
saying man you can use my natural
leanness as a bonding I've been watching
you guys from afar and then seeing what
you're doing I'm seeing you on the red
carpet now which is that must be a
a whole different animal for you I mean
it's kind of this it's got a show
Showtime Showtime show to rock an old
stepson good old stepdad bride and daddy
over here the old graying [ __ ]
dinosaur it was a barnacle when you guys
talk amongst ourselves honest to God
when he got the Showtime Danny got the
and he's doing everybody carpet jealous
I mean and you and you and you you kind
of you kind of like shoved at your heart
like my heart yeah well they just I've
just figured that yeah I mean I'll never
be the same and I consider him a traitor
but I'm not a happy form I'm happy the
guy wants to leave me in the dust that's
who I like off
I'm happy for how good congratulations
to see you how tough is it with your
schedule being on the road stuff like
that with a kid oh it's you know when
you go with the kid on the road it's a
little once a challenging but just a
little different you don't have that
time to yourself that you might need I
mean like in LA and you you know you're
gonna test this be because my son wakes
up at five depending on the day five or
six if I do a spot at the Comedy Store
and I get home by say midnight 12:30 and
he's up about five yeah that's the beef
listen I gotta tell you my my daughter
sleeps like a bear so really she gets up
around 7:30 8:00 lucky man
so it's two sleeping is not an issue for
my wife and I and we hear a lot of
parents say oh you know getting up in
this in any I think my baby knock on
wood 12 hours solids I'm not he's not a
peep so might be like you you're not
never seen you hyped
or stressed in my life what stresses you
out making too much stress knows what I
like I have do I buy last man do I [ __ ]
in my teeth I had some seaweed before I
came
um I feel like hanging on my teeth oh no
I don't get overly excited you right I
don't get overly excited and I don't get
too overly stressed out it's easy just
even yeah I get excited when I'm around
people like my wife or my parents I'll
show a lot of excitement if something
nice happens to me but like my manager
agents you know they'll call with good
news am I on it's great and then they're
like hey do you care been waiting you
know you're kind of at the top of the
mountain right now so after a while it's
all gravy I mean after a while maybe
it's like you be like cuz with Brian
he'll get some news I'll get super
excited for him or all you get news all
super excited he's like no no no no
chill man chill in the business hola
yeah it's a long haul and also your
barnacles yeah also your life isn't
gonna change that much for me like what
I get excited about is writing new stuff
or what I get excited about it's trying
to do something that I have I didn't
think I could do you know maybe a great
new hour or something like that and that
requires a lot of time and a lot of
meditation and a lot of repetition and
all the [ __ ] that we you know we all
talk about but then the rest of it is I
don't know like all due respect the
Huntsville Alabama but there's not I
love doing the crowds and I love the
people but there's not a whole lot else
I can do right I mean did maybe it was
you get older what is exciting I mean I
like learning something new but it's not
like let's go party but for some guys
like Sebastian level you're at a lot of
calm then you see you know I could give
you an endless list of names they get to
a certain place where the sound out
arenas theaters Radio City mass square
garden and then they just go to the
movie so they go to TV you don't see in
return unless they have to you know I
would never abandon stand-up comedy it's
something that I I really enjoy doing
and I've dabbled a little bit in the the
TV I had TV shows for show yeah yeah he
came out he was between you and forgot
that guy's name
go with the other guy I don't give up do
you vote against me
we're friends there was a lot of people
involved it there was a lot of people
that weird for you at all like
auditioning for me and the wrong and so
on yes who just like a pro I don't think
about it I you know I mean you guys are
trying to solve a problem
did you never take that personally I
come in
you should I might fit in with the rest
of the crowd or I might not you know
there are a lot of parts I get a lot of
parts I don't and that's just the way
that's the books I do a good job a no
joke yeah a lot of those [ __ ]
sometimes they don't know it's not the
room is divided sometimes just like yeah
but no and then three people say the
best was that more work than you thought
doing that TV show yeah it was a lot of
pay cut to that's the funny thing I was
passionate he does a TV show he's taking
a major pay cut yes there's not a lot of
them there's not a lot of money is that
there's money in it but you know nothing
different yeah it's just different money
at a later date but yeah it was a lot of
work behind the part do you are you
thinking about buying and wearing a cape
or are you gonna stay fit ground ask you
a little about where I get a cape yeah
I've been watching the assassination
show by the assassination I have not
seen that is it good yes it's so good it
is how good is they act it how good the
act of the kid who the murderer oh yeah
this unbelievable I think this guy came
out of Glee right I don't know did he
yeah he kill himself that the actual guy
he's committed murder yeah
spoiler alert
murder but he came himself yeah he did
they they're in in the ocean I think he
went on a boat and committed suicide was
that where it was yeah yeah Andrew
Cunanan is the guy on I wrote a whole
op-ed about Versace and the family and
it really they were like such evil
what's out that sorry an editorial you
know you know my only problem with the
with the v8 the FX show the
assassination Versace they barely talked
about Versace it's more about the murder
which is fine I like the how it's
different but what's her name Donatello
yeah Donatella she was not that hot
Penelope Cruz should not be playing that
role I thought they'd miss Kathy you've
seen what you don't tell her how she
looks like now have you ever seen her
she does not really know bleak room you
just do it before and after yeah I think
there's a lot of work done to her with
blonde wig no I know I looked her up oh
that's her now yes
that's her on the right she's a
character from Blade 3 yes well before
you know what before I could see
Penelope Cruz a little bit I retract my
statement I don't see any Penelope Cruz
at all any time she said but yes see
Penelope in the actual role yeah it's
just tough I don't know why these
plastic surgeons don't say hey money for
them what are they gonna do yeah I want
to do it but it is a great show how I
don't know we started the session al
Versace but yeah it's a great show
sure do you uh you only guys who adapt
like a lot of old-school comedians now
with social media that's kind of like
your own PR you know yeah you can do is
not at your level it's different but you
can do radio or you can podcasts are
definitely the way to go over radio but
there's also two avenues you can do but
you're kind of your own publicist now
with your own social media so you see
guys like phenomenal comedians and I see
some all the time we're phenomenal they
don't sell tickets cuz they tear about
social media that's what I learned from
him that's their outlet is such a block
from it but I just finally start I've
noticed your social media on your page
has definitely dipped I don't see you
doing as much as you used to you used to
do a lot
yeah Instagram no I do a lot I don't see
I'm just saying you used to do this iPad
thing yeah sorry that I thought that was
really creative and I don't see a lot of
that and I got a start I'm not saying
you're not doing a lot I'm just saying
those types of things I used to see I
used to see you in you know on the beach
and jumping up in the air I missed those
photos yeah I hear dip I'm like it's
like telling you I'll get back on it
we've seen a dip in your effectiveness
if you I think if you went back and
looked at your Instagram I think you
would see a decline in your activity
yeah
over the last year I'm saying if you go
back a year from now there was a lot
more think you would be doing stuff in
the car yeah you're both more the
graphic I got to start doing work that's
the challenge though and I've dealt with
this is is how much of your social media
is promoting your shows and how much is
it a little peek into your life and
whatnot so here's the thing I think goes
the furthest is they know Sebastian's
comedians Sebastian's celebrity and
obviously you're gonna have shows but if
you post in like more stuff that they
can't find online or something like that
your personal life goes so much further
and they're gonna like you you as a
person buy tickets yeah I think that
it's all kind of in the same ecosystem
and yeah Kevin Hart does a good job of
that [ __ ]
Kevin arts writing about the rocks
amazing at it you look it like the top
guys the rocks just ridiculous well yeah
if you look at the rock every time he
gets on I talk about positive this guy
is like every time he's smiling he's
amazing it's like it takes me like so
much time to do everyone I don't know
but it takes me five six times maybe to
get a video I gotta this guy looks like
he just throws the camera I go hey let's
go up guys we're we're watching my show
here we got my my age in here and
it's the best video of all time with
well-articulated everything so damn lit
and he's jacked and Jack that of his
mind what's he how did they turn off
hahahaha would you say what's he taking
I want to get involved every steroid
every steroid for five thousand that's
for sure yes every steroid in the book I
mean damn he shoot my wife he turns off
he's like God he's just like road rage I
don't know whatever he doesn't have you
seen this perfect daughter let's keep
that little girl is oh my god oh look at
that wind can we say out of those eyes
how're ya always laughing smart always
in the best teeth everyday perfect
alright and can you say daddy is the
most handsome brilliant sexiest might be
an appropriate time and say all that
perfect yeah she's gotta be fair society
that's like that's like if you look at
Roger Federer or the greatest tennis
player of all time
they had his kids in awe in the audience
and they were dressed in like suits and
ties and like it's like a it's like a
polo ad even the guy was now seeing
those your greatest tennis player in the
world and you got kids that stepped out
of a polo means come on not much more
huh though I mean the rocks daughter's
free she looks like the character from
Alana
it's unbelievable yeah she's stunning my
social medias good though that's the
point of this you know social media is
good it's just gonna dip is they gonna
dip and I'd like to see a little bit
more coming out easy that's what were
you at the economy Brian eyes tells me
because I know the comic stories just I
mean they're sold out Monday through
Sunday which is crazy right we use their
turn the dark age I guess yeah really we
were both there it was awful
it was we didn't know Alex and the main
in the
in the original room 12 alcoholics I'm
not kidding
nursing their drinks scattered scattered
and you'd go up right am i wrong all the
time
mmm the the thing I remember most about
the Comedy Store in the 98 99 2000 is
they had to wait to start the show
because nobody was there so sure starts
at 9:00 nobody in the room you would
call start yet no nobody here at 9:30
anybody and we got to the original room
was the only room running all week and
then main room was open on Saturday
night that's it and the fact we would
open usually it'd be like Thursday
Friday Saturday I think the Laugh
Factory yeah I never did the laughs at
3:00 early on I started doing that maybe
around 2005 Jamie Masada when I when I
auditioned for him early on he goes you
so angry about what angry Sam Kinison
angry but purpose you have no purpose
yeah there was slim pickins at the
Comedy Store
would it became it's like I can't
believe all they come like this now yeah
it's like it's never been like this dude
no II never you know you do I did a
half-hour show for one Israeli guy one
time in the or dude he was calling this
I was like this is the greatest audience
ever I did a solid hard one a half-hour
and the best show of his life he was
dying cackling like how do I leave well
they left me up there didn't used to do
did we used to do [ __ ] up there I'm not
on if you ever saw me do this but we
would do [ __ ] where I would like I'd
have my underwear on only Rogan one time
is laughing so [ __ ] hard because they
were like again they were probably 21
people in the audience scattered and I
had I was in my underwear and I was
doing calisthenics and I think I was
trying to lead big the crowd they were
all [ __ ] just drugged I thought come
on let's go let's go do it let's go deep
and now let's just stand here for a
while let's just crunch here see you
guys now you're not gonna get your level
I'm in my hurry you're not gonna get to
this level obviously please
like in there I didn't even know it was
him he was laughing so slow that's the
kind of [ __ ] you just get away with no I
wish I would have seen that I've never
seen you in your underwear upset Oh
resurgence is just you know you think
the research is just from the deep deep
roster of phenomenal comedians I mean I
don't know do you know yeah
the there's so many comedians over there
that have a following that if if one of
them is going on social media
yeah social media to the economy stars
really really paid attention to their
social media the best two or three years
you can go there and you can see
Sebastian Joe Rogan Dave Chappelle Chris
Rock I mean Chris D'Elia are you the
best comics in the world on a Monday
night on a Monday and a Tuesday night
and now you by the way how much to cost
you 20 bucks 20 bucks and now you don't
even you don't even need to look at the
roster you know this can be heavy
hitters so you just need to get the
ticket that's right you wanna go see
some of the best comedians in the world
it's crazy it's just good day night yeah
yeah yeah so that's a nice place to work
out it's the only place I feel the most
comfortable to try out really really
brand new material that's so when she
said cuz Joy Diaz was he's the ops that
he goes man I used to be able to you
know try my new stuff out at the comic
store but now you know your fault not
that Joey Diaz cares but your following
you Sebastian Brian bill burr Marc mayor
and so and no one's really trying out
new stuff so you got to bring your a you
know your a material because everyone
else is just thinking about you you've
been thrown into this as doing stamp
comedy you've been thrown into a mix of
some of the best and like ever yeah it's
a high bar so it's a good thing for you
because this is like I don't know yeah
you know it's it's it's a are you
picking up tips and stuff from me all
year around
non-stop yeah yeah yeah I have I bring
that hey soos Trio who's a oh yeah he's
a guy who's always at the Comedy Store
he's a regular there I bring him with me
whenever I'm on the road he opens and
then I'll ask him to say hey what watch
out if he can't and I'll pay him extra I
watch the sets if you have any notes any
buttons any any set I do at the Comedy
Store bright Brian or Tripoli or D'Elia
I ask them to help me Rogen helps me
Rogen open up for me at the Wilbur in
Boston and then he watched look mile
he's never seen me doing how he watched
my full set and then we went back and
exchanged notes afterwards so yeah as
much as I can get to me I'm in training
camp non-stop for this stuff so yeah
we're always learning I just feel like
if you're if you're around a lot of
comedians
everybody's got like a different way of
looking at how they do it if you start
like really analyzing how I'm sorry I
was out to dinner with drop a name is
just sign fell down your hand yeah a few
things about comedy Jerry Seinfeld look
a billion dollars by the way yeah we
went for pizza just like for me when you
come to my show I want to make it more
of an experience not only for the just
to stand up I want if people are gonna
pay this type of money they're gonna
come out and get a babysitter and
they're gonna pay for parking and
they're gonna do all this I take it
really really seriously because I don't
want a half asset I don't want to I
don't want to do any of that just
because this is a business and if people
come and they go ain't gonna come back
so we disrespect you know for the effort
that they're making yeah yeah I feel
like people are coming into my house and
I gotta have a lot of food for them to
eat
yeah so that's why I look at these shows
you know I I did this this show and I
want to populate the screens before the
show with stuff that is fan engagement
you know like a hash tag stay hungry
we'll throw the picture up there so they
could they could see their photo I did a
sort of a kiss cam I did a Sebastian
face cam where the camera come on you
and you got to make
like one of my faces just leave just
have a little interactive rather than
who's going to a show you sit there and
you wait for the comedian and hey you
laugh and you go home you know I show
you promise yeah it's like a show a show
you want to have have a little photo
booth outside if people want to take my
future but I want to make it more of
experience for people
yeah than just a stand-up comedy show
because in this day and age with all
that's going on and everybody's
attention is so split in as 18 different
directions you really have to keep
people engaged and I feel like when you
come to one of my shows hopefully you
leave going I can't wait to tell a
couple more people come back and inside
Phil's saying the same thing well yeah
well that's we weren't we were just
talking in general about about stand-up
comedy and about TV shows and do you
need a TV show you know back in the 80s
you needed a TV show to kind of catapult
your stand-up career because that's how
you kind of got the word out to a broad
audience now man it's like these
comedians they don't really they don't
really need it thank you should do a TV
show and it hurts your numbers because
it doesn't translate mm-hmm you do a
sitcom on ABC you might get boxed in as
that it doesn't translate I don't know
why but you know I've been on the
Goldbergs for four years now it's a
really popular character but it thats
not what sells tickets this sells
tickets you know and and and then the
local press and then some people like oh
but but there's no way for me to tell
them what I'm doing the Goldbergs that
I'm going to be in their town mm-hmm
character too
yeah and that's yeah yeah and people are
tuning in here they're getting to know
you guys and now the your comedy is you
so when you go out there they know what
they're kind of getting it's like plus
the podcast audience I believe is a
different audience entirely I mean I
would I would venture horrible yeah
younger too right
yeah just depends you know 1836 our
demographic but
they're more loyal if you're gonna to
not tune into a podcast with Brian hi
you're basically listen to us at least
for four hours a week if you listen to
my other shows you listen to me for six
to eight hours a week if I'm come to
your town you're a loyal dude man Wow
and it's also different too because when
I was fighting or I'm sure people on TV
shows get the same thing when I was
fighting people would come up to eat
they don't know me they know me from
doing a pre-interview of a I'm about to
get a fist fight with another grown-ass
man so it's not it's not that I'm a
character but I'm saying stuff to sell
the fight it's violent stuff so they
would approach me that way and I didn't
know them they didn't know me I was like
oh my god man get out of here and I
don't need this in the podcast they
listen this enough where it's never
awkward when I meet people I know you
they know me inside and out if they do
listen the show it's like we're old
friends the other thing is that we give
this away for free and always have and
always will and I think that there's
something about that for people they
really appreciate it and in a way they
kind of feel like they want to they want
to give back - mm-hmm because like I've
had people say go you give you've given
us so much free content for so long like
of course I'm gonna buy a ticket to your
show mm-hmm you know there's an
interesting thing there were and that
was something I talked to Rogan about a
long time ago did you and Seinfeld talk
about Porsches at all he's like mr.
Porsche yeah he's he's so into the
Porsche like I don't know what's under
the hood I'm not that guy
he's his master's degree and yeah he
knows like in 1956 they came out with
too much I don't know any that I just
drove a damn thing you know I don't know
a lot about anything I just I don't get
detailed but you went on not really but
you went on comedians in cars getting
coffee right yeah oh boy
yeah yeah we became fast friends over
the last three years and it's a here's a
guy who's been through all of that the
Stevie show the touring and the whole
thing and any time when I have like a
question about the business and that's
good
so yep Seinfeld I've Rogen and Brian
yeah yeah you have these guys in your
career you know
by the way when he did the when he
ventured off and did his own podcast
he's got another one right jealous I
mean do I feel the trade again of course
but I'm not jealous I'm not you know I'm
not jealous you know I have Boyle T yes
ten percent what I do and it should be
twenty percent but I don't give up how
do I get drunk on the rooftop and I do
ice cream I made you I mean nobody's
there to hear it so it doesn't matter
speaking of you talked to Seinfeld I'll
talk to him and Rogan I feel like in
sports it's not like this and in comedy
I had and I'm sure there's guys out
there who cannot stand me and I get out
hate me too but I feel the comedy family
has embraced me like I didn't think they
would oh I usually think that you
weren't gonna be what I thought we were
gonna hate me yeah I was always super
self-conscious I walk in a room and ask
Brian hey why are you in the corner like
huddled up cuz I didn't want to like but
you know walk around and peacock out so
I would I just go there and get ready do
my setting like get out but then be like
oh where you going man everyone's I
think you I think you would have been in
many ways because comics are not the
nicest people but I think there's
something that what you're saving grace
was that you had done you already kind
of proven yourself in the podcast space
but also like you you know you can't
take away the like like the calluses
that you've gotten see a lot of times
commas go you want to be a comic be an
actor's one thing you want to be a comic
that means you got a grind on the road
get up alone and do all that you got in
a cage in your underwear no it's a big
different no but I'm telling you for
comics when you see a guy who's gotten
into a cage in his underwear and fought
like that that creates a callus that is
it's so there's a grit there there's
kind of a grit and there's and you can
see it on your ears and so it's hot it's
it's in a way be respecting but the do
expect like even for me in this con
black like I'll see other won't be nice
about this
I'll see other athletes trying comedy
yeah because they've seen my not put
this in quotes success depends what you
want to say success but see my success
of their doing comedy yeah and all judge
them like you have no idea but also
because you've wanted to be a comic your
whole life right that's the other thing
the big difference is that you've always
been really artistic
you've always been in the fashion you've
always been in that's the biggest thing
is that the truth is you have always
wanted to be either a singer a dancer an
actor or a [ __ ] comedian I'm case the
best yeah we don't care about you but
it's happened enough get off of me
Sebastian you have a goal as far as
specials you want to do you're trying to
compete with the a when the specials
ready it's ready I'm not trying you're
not trying out some the ten and you know
ten yeah that didn't do we gotta get the
pen no I'm just saying that's uh God did
for me specials I'm never I'm never
going to put out a special just to put
one out I put it out when it's ready and
I'm not trying to attain a certain
certain number of specials but I did
want to hit a point in regards to what
we were talking about with this stand-up
comedy and you coming into Seattle
comedy when you were fighting night and
a guy came in let's say he was from
another profession let's say it was a
baseball player with a lot of football
players come okay so do you go what you
were a football player right now okay do
you look at the football player yeah you
don't know what it takes for sure
yes exactly yeah so it's like the
inherit thing is if you're in a
profession and you've been doing it for
a while a new guy comes in from another
profession I think it's always going to
be there's always going to be like hey
man this is different animal and whatnot
and then especially when you have the
success that you've been having doing it
yeah of course you're gonna get people
looking at you going
the [ __ ] is this guy doing and I'm not
like just say I am never like that and
I'm taking these people out there they
are and I never understood it like I'm
all [ __ ] aside like this the
jealousy and all that I have never
looked at this I think a lot of its like
how do you look at it I never looked at
this career as a competition it has
nothing to do with me like I have enough
time competing with myself and trying to
do what I'm doing
so whether my buddy over here is blowing
up or whether Rogen is I that has
nothing to do I never think of I never
think Oh the pie is getting smaller yeah
oh no I there's not enough for me I
never that doesn't make any sense ever
made sense to me and I think it's a very
bad way to think no it's a ridiculous
way that is a bad way for anything it
should be you see your friends close to
you killing it like you is I've that's
kind of inspiring it's exciting
especially when they're doing it the
right way I guess maybe sometimes you
see somebody who is popular for whatever
reason and has no talent and they blow
up but I don't care about that either I
don't want to be that because that's not
really substantive you know yeah so do
you know this there's it's really a
question the perspective that you take
in how you look at things this [ __ ] is
hard enough with on your it's hard
enough competing with your [ __ ] self
competing with other people in comparing
I don't know how to do that I mean I
understand it's very human I do I
understand that but it's it's a bad idea
no I get you let me talk on the guest do
you have the same kind of process as far
as when you write as sine field does not
monster I mean I don't know if you watch
the is last specially at all's notes
yeah that's why that's where I get it
from yeah I don't have no notes I don't
work I don't write I go up on stage I
will I go to County certain tonight know
tomorrow night and I will talk about my
experience within the last week about
going to SoulCycle or about going to my
buddy's business and how that business
looks it's just like telling a story
it's telling a story like I call my
Michael
listen what happen at soul cycle today I
walked in and it's the same thing that I
will do on stage I don't sit in the room
going all right you know did the Kallen
and Brendan show what was it so far but
I think that's why again when I when I
do I guess homework or for inspiration
when I look at comics you're one of them
because your storyteller yeah - all
stories so so if you're a a joke teller
you're gonna have to write the jokes
down but I record all my sets I go and
get my car and I listen to it on the
ride home and I listen to the next
morning and then hopefully I'll get up
on stage the next night and then just
keep honing it hone and hone it and and
that's the kind of way I work but the
Seinfeld works in a way where it's like
I'm like man you this guy's folders and
folders have you ever seen that is
special yeah I sit in the street and
they laid them all out back and it's
like and I know guys Grogan's a guy who
writes every morning yeah some guys
that's the one thing that I've learned
from all cuz I'll talk to Delia off to
you Carolyn wrote it BRR everyone has
their process now Owens there's no sir
Oh make sure you spend an hour every day
and write this they actually do this
I'll set a timer sometimes though if I
feel like I'm scattered and I and I
won't look at my phone or anything and
I'll just sit and wait till something
happens or I'll go over my prob for me I
write because I keep going over my set
like right don't you feel if you just
keep going over it you're it's like
D'Elia
he went on after me and he just got back
from Australia Knotts tell him how good
Australia's he's never been there and so
he booked a trip down he's like one of
the reasons I went cuz you went down
there so he goes down there does all
these theater sells out and then he
comes back that night you know D'Elia
was crazy work ethic he goes right to
the stage and tells a story on him
flying to Australia and going through
all of it I know dang man would you
write dahlias alright I didn't I'd
literally that story just happened to
him and I'm like Dan that was an extra
story he kills like yes but you know I
find the
of where the fun is yeah and it was so
damn good man yeah taunt story yeah I go
you don't write that day it's not never
right yeah it's amazing to find out how
these people work what story you're
gonna tell about me in this podcast I
don't know where I'm gonna go with no
energy something in your mouth I have I
have a podcast myself I didn't know that
yes and it's been on for five years it's
obviously not as 1t it's been on for
five years yeah it's it's not as
successful we don't have a brick wall
that's so tired he's got his he's got
his Showtime studio in here as well okay
this is another thing you're doing here
the other thing yeah yeah yeah no I'm
not we've already got my pocket I know I
just noticed you weren't on the wall my
podcast for Christ's sake okay yeah just
going where do you fit it caricatures of
me right there you know I like to chin
verse count yeah yeah I do and it's
similar to yours in the sense that we
well and similar it's two two buddies
kind of getting who's the other Pete
Cory Ali Frankie's a comedian and
there's Pete live in LA no we do it via
you know never go anywhere but anyway we
don't have sponsors yeah we don't have a
horse's head in the wall or anything
like that you can't just say no by the
way the fighter and the kid did you do
somebody make that fair yeah see fans
don't send us that but we do that that
guy's a genius that guy remember do you
ever think do you ever think about going
and I'm not saying not in you're so busy
so it's almost now that I'm saying out
loud sounds stupid never thought of
going the bird Tullio out where it's
just you riffing like once a week no no
no this works really well with Pete and
I
it's called the Pete and Sebastien show
and it works really really well I don't
think I could get on and talk for one
yourself with a beat by myself yes
that's not my style at all I tip my hat
to those guys that do that but yeah yeah
and it's been good we have very very
loyal listeners as you well know the
podcast section like this no I was
looking at I'm trying to see what the
thing is over four five years yes right
these are two comics who've been at it
forever great cop no guests we have no
guests it's just kind of me and him
talking have me on I'll give you a bump
well give you once once well we don't
really have a studio I do it out of my
house they don't have the surroundings
how often do you so once a week once a
week it's on every Friday I'm sorry
what's your name chin
we don't have chin yeah don't have a guy
oh yeah actually we do but he's he's
remote this DJ Lou he's in New York
kinda puts it all together
miss young disaster no Irene's been
doing long enough it's good and then the
book was come out you got so quarter
your [ __ ] podcaster oh yeah I'm sure
that was really really take it's great
but what about the book and you pointed
the book
you waved at that screen your point of
the book okay now it's here the book is
here I mean yeah that's why I say that
fantastic I keep one of these Sebastian
yeah sign for you thank you sir yeah
Tony Danza says a really good read from
beginning to end with laughs at every
stop all right Tony yeah JJ what Wow
you don't even watch football the
compelling and inspiring story of
Sebastian's rise to the top of the
comedy roll that's all I said
is it I need to say why don't you have
me Daniel yellow be one of the funniest
but one of the funniest man alive was
just true this is a textbook on how to
keep fighting when everything is telling
you to go home how I made it will
inspire you that's good
I like that yeah that's a saying I think
this books are gonna relate to more
people than any of these other
celebrities or anything like that cuz
your journey we can all relate to it
yeah the book is out it came out last
week you could pick it up at Amazon or
Barnes & Noble
it took a while like I said to write my
wife and I wrote it together oh man she
really helped me out with it she was
very instrumental in getting those
stories out why do you not wear your
hair like that oh my gosh I don't like
to call it on my mom like that hold on
did you look like that only trying to
sell those dish no no this is pre dish
when I was at a conference soccer I did
not know that yeah that's that was my
son make sense yeah you were a good
athlete yeah make sense cuz you move
well on spin I like um well holds over a
second I hold on for a sec well we got
it I mean if you well that's just
wearing a vest right there look at the
chest on the kick that's an Italian
dressed like Aladdin you're a classy
young bull right ya know that's the
romance frank grillo and i appreciate
that yeah it's in the weeds off the off
ramp at the Rockford Illinois
either photographer open your shirt down
this way right that's it there's the why
your mother's I got the sexy mother
thought that was like you're serious
about Michael Jackson this picture of
you oh yeah that's fifth grade my ice
cream social doing Billie Jean this is
yeah I'm uh it's so good to see you do
this ad having known you so long and
haven't been such a hero to you I know I
have an inspiration to see to see sort
of somebody I considered my pup ya know
not to be a dick but I felt like I was
always feeding you and then and then now
you've sprouted wings and you're you're
actually soaring this so well I I thank
you for that now I can shoot you down
anytime I [ __ ] lightly tread lightly
cuz I'll load my shotgun right now I'm
breaking I will make her speak
wait wait tell them what you said tell
them what you how you how you what yeah
yeah and describe something to actually
you know what I I burned a book because
I spelled your name wrong at first I
didn't know you went with a why it's not
really well does turn on any TV any TV
station Wow I had to go to your
Instagram and that's where I saw the dip
so yeah here's your this is are you 32
years old
you wrote to Brian are you 32 years old
that's fantastic
I just wrote it in the car I'm yeah um
this man so yeah and I'm not just saying
cuz you're here Sebastian these are my
favorite books to read man I like you
know I read sign fields book I read Judd
Apatow's book alright so you're reading
you're reading you're gonna do a book on
tape with this it is it is yeah it's
audio including your voice yeah I heard
those are a monster to do it was one of
the hardest things that I already do
have you ever heard this week the people
who do books on tape I believe it it you
know yeah it's hours and you got a five
hours a day it was five session for five
hours and I yes when I read it's not you
know I mean listen I don't read a begin
one yeah so when I'm reading out loud
even though I wrote the damn travel it
was like there's just like two people
editing you as you're going so acting
yeah in in your ear you'll go uh they'll
go uh you you said could and there's no
could in the sentence I was adding words
I was subtracting words it's difficult I
heard like one of the toughest things to
do I'll be mark just do it for his book
you know and he goes dude I thought this
gonna be fun I was all excited to do it
but and some people they don't want to
deal with it so they have someone else
read it it doesn't work man Meryl
Streep's done this in four books I mean
a lot of actors do it and it's you know
different thanks brother chilly menu
because I knew someone was gonna be here
just to know it was gonna be you so I
just I just put I want your career in
there cuz you you're silly
chin you have any interests
singing okay country oh you don't
yeah okay it's a CH AI n Jin yeah that's
right the way the stereotypical way to
sell yeah so I don't know why I'm saying
this on the show but yeah um is that it
yeah no I figured it'd be nice is this
video yeah you watch oh I know one you
guys are successful yeah not only audio
but you could pick this up on like a
like a you told you to 200,000 250,000
subscribe to learn $1 200 am a plaque
the [ __ ] do you think you're dealing
we're just apply it's somewhere we used
to hang up Lackey just what put it in
the corner plank well when you get a
hundred thousand we shattered that is
100 but then it's already it's around
200 no question the gold I want to woke
up will go silver what's with the shoes
on the table you know you can ask
Brendan you by the way who makes your
shoes you got a judge in Colorado
oh those are nice you know the airport
yeah they're not that that those are not
represent you know you you are a clothes
you're you're you're like Brendan you
you're not you walk into a room don't be
surprised if you got five thousand
dollars on your body I make a call right
now I'm making the call right now cuz
I'm looking at the watch and the shoes
you top and your top of the tens right
now you could be tell you're not gonna
watch those beads no you have no idea
now let me see it he's Italian not to
give you a clue it was a gift I don't
buy a lot
I don't mind you know my son all right
what is an Italian it wasn't an italian
submarine
people I think the Italians wore this
not to the stallion Navy right and tell
you baby so it's not crazy expensive I
don't know details oh I know details
Brennan just looked around I thought she
was so great it's one of the it's a
great watch so say your studio you are
in the studio you're on YouTube with I
don't know ten thousand dollars on your
body at least I don't know about ten
thousand dollars
yeah the day you can go rob you can go
to the but you can go to the bottom of
the ocean that thing's not gonna shatter
that's what I know
Graham you're probably right on that
brother right on that but no I don't
like to I don't like to this is you know
this is normal jeans no no no your
regular guy regular guy yeah the more
you had them loom to your body but they
were long to your body because you
played soccer so you got amplify yeah
you're not getting you know you know
wearing skinny jeans cuz you're a man
and you spend a lot of time on a field
well actually no one I do have a pair of
skinny jeans kind of tight around the
calves because my calves are you got
calves that you your your legs have made
your whole body is built to bear down
instead if you say so
well there's a long march I'm throwing a
rucksack on your back you're carrying
the food you're not breaking down right
hey man you don't know when I'll eat
when I leave here and I look up rock
sack whatever that is you know you said
another word early on and this is the
podcast oh where did you hear that long
word that came out of his mouth yeah was
that was that does the versace
is like the documentary but what was it
no notnot a eulogy thing it started with
an a like a pot you said something uh
path did you know that said that's that
that's chin just stick to see if we were
if we relist into this was an apology
today you know
it's it's right in the beginning I and I
acted like I knew what you were talking
about I do it all the time
yeah there there are words that I that I
was at Antebellum did I use the word
priests pre-civil war no there was a
woman sitting next to me on the plane
and she she looked at the guy and she
said across the aisle she goes do you
know what this word means
and I went I couldn't help it and I went
and the word was pogrom and I happen to
have known what pogrom means because
it's doesn't matter but I I went into a
long explanation of what the word is
it's actually a Yiddish word that is
what the Jews used for when the Russians
when when the non-jews would come in and
basically kill you or blame you for
something it was a pogrom they would
periodically a czar with neck inflation
is bad the crops suck plagues let's
blame the Jews and the Jews were kept in
what they were called pails these like
ghettos and they just send a bunch of
hugging you know Russians in they
basically raised their kills everybody
here [ __ ] mop or whatever Adams
called it for Grom Wow I'm out okay no
I'm glad I don't know that's already
saying this if somebody asked you next
week what a pogrom is did you even
listen to that zero zero bro
she did the same thing Isis clean I was
staring at this I swear to god she did
the sinning and I realized it was him I
went this is too long explanation and I
and I spoke too soon
she doesn't care I don't care anymore
and nobody else is gonna care about this
story and I just proved it oh you've
insulted me for a good hour now this is
all like Boston shop no no don't buy
this man's book he's one of the best in
the business man well I appreciate you
guys having me on what is this air like
in the summer yeah
stay hard like the wheel if to that 19
second bump the way Netflix you
ungrateful [ __ ] let's be out
what chin today tomorrow tonight tonight
one will blast it out we're seeing a
spike in sales no price yeah Amazon
Barnes & Noble whatever you get booked
for you don't let me plug something I'm
doing I'm doing a book signing here at
the Grove at the Barnes & Noble on
tomorrow actually Tuesday so Tuesday
yeah what time I think it's at 7 o'clock
of it overs on Tuesday at the Grove
tomorrow night at the Grove 7 o'clock
yes that's a sign he gets Sprinkles
Cupcakes and get a signature it's not a
mansion you got this up quick man first
time yeah so yeah it's tomorrow so come
by tomorrow
man it's up all that was there was uh
signing was Kevin Hart oh yeah rhymes
noble growth oh yes the best oh man I
love Kevin do you know Kevin uh I don't
know him no the best no um alright my
favorite guys thank you for having me on
thank you man
we love you you're great Sebastian's God
we can let our hair down
bastions gone we can let our hair down
take our pants off and suck until
they're off cause gay had to go there
you did know I was making joking you say
cuz were gay Wow well extremely wrong
with that
alright I like that you're willing to
throw back master Kim's shirt yeah like
how was Huntsville Alabama Brian I've
been Alabama it's actually lovely well
the the problem is that you go to the
towns and it's one [ __ ] big
conglomerate after another what happened
to small businesses I don't even know
I'm not kidding it's this everything had
to be Chipotle and Panera you could
blindfold me and drop me in Huntsville
or or or some other Illinois and I don't
Nationals different but darling
yeah these places where Seattle there's
no difference
I wouldn't know that there's anything
about it Alabama the whole beds because
look at where the comedy clubs are at
they put them around those similar
that's yeah unless you're going to
theaters all corners it all have to be
these huge companies when you're a kid
and you're growing up there you have a
chant you can go work at Panera or you
can work at Foot Locker you can work
it's the same thing I'm just saying what
a girl it's America how was our bama
though it was fine any good food to be
honest with you taco was really good
local taco local so I was started in
Nashville and this guy want her name is
anything great cook and it was some of
the best tacos I've ever had Ashley
doesn't have any barbecue down there
anything no barbecue no you know what no
there is a place cool coffee shop called
alchemy did uh man it's we don't bunch
of alchemy coffee shops which is strange
but did uh did a bunch of scientists
show up to your shows they would and I
asked I would like any scientists and
none of them did yet because you know
why the busy I don't want my scientist
at a goddamn comic show you're busy
they're trying to get to goddamn more
yeah and not only that and I really
loved everybody at the club at Stan
apply the [ __ ] great everybody who
worked there this guy Tom everybody a a
Christian who runs it but hey hey can
you not start the Saturday early show at
6:30
oh you mean what people need I mean it's
a bad idea
oh why was it 6:30 I guess it's Central
Time I don't give a [ __ ] that's too
early it's Charlie too early for comedy
Charlie way too early it sterling Ock
man special East Coast I was like what
are you doing to me is that considered
East Coast time or is it central East
Coast right it's central it's a two
hours it's two hours behind those three
oh no two hours ahead I should say two
hours ahead yeah yeah man I had I had
fun though I I had fun I always have fun
no matter who I am you opened for a
local guy yeah and by the way though
I'll tell you something about people
from yeah they were really funny I'll
tell you thing about Alabama uh
don't insult any blue sea in the south
in the south I can say thing I can say
this with with if you are polite to
people they are the nicest coolest
people on the planet now now please
understand something about Alabama
everybody has a gun on their personage
mmm if they don't they got it in the
truck and that's a fact
hmm and it's not uncommon to see a man
walking through Kmart or Walmart with
his a K with his ar-15 strapped over his
shoulder
now hold on love shootings are those
hold on
probably not now here's the thing about
the South I did a thing where my last
joke I went I do that global warming bit
where I'm like people aren't educated
you don't get the joke and I wanted
Alabama yeah but I was joking that's all
that be the huh woman goes she said
something like who you calling who you
calling uneducated you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] white girl ha ha and older
older than me older than me notice she
would say also a table full of other
white haired people but they were
southerners and they were rather proud
so don't be coming in as a Yankee and
telling anybody I was joking because I'd
you stay away do you say shut up gravy
chop no I got her back because we say it
as I went shut up macaroni and cheese
sure kids sure didn't I got her back
because what I did was I went I
acknowledged it I added in but I had to
I had to stop it might have to
incorporate it because it was that nasty
and mean and it was violent she says yes
sir so I had to I had to bring in a to
kick that [ __ ] and I got her back I got
her back I said then I go where's my
girl am I getting you back then she was
like yeah dang but yeah and that's
always been the case in the south
your stupid mom [ __ ] don't insult
somebody's honor don't [ __ ] with
somebody's girl
that's comedy show though so group of
lightly shut the [ __ ] up yeah it's calm
down I'm a comic I'm cops Lee joke and I
come all around the nation comic joking
but not joking about you apparently
apparently you're on educate cuz you're
the only one that took offense care to
see this gentleman here which NASA
laughed at the joke he's educated slug
there you go you all see can't read my
mr. Keith I woulda made it worse I know
it's not the way to handle it yeah well
what was funny is some of the guys
wet the club I go the guys who work
there and I said something to the effect
they go you see you know in the under
and the coast in New York and I'm in LA
they would have a judgement about the
south and they had these like
stereotypes of rednecks and I'm and I'm
talking to you guys and you're also
smart and you're just so [ __ ] with it
and it's a I you dick goes to show you
all the [ __ ] stereotypes I think I
grew up in Alabama's all look at this
well actually you're wrong about that if
you walked in wearing nail polish you
were a guy that cut your [ __ ] fingers
off like Jesus Christ
I love Alabama old school Jesus I'll
tell you one who's from Alabama
dominating box right now the great
Deontay Wilder is he from Alabama I
didn't know that born and raised
damn right of Alabama that crimson
football the yet good sports down there
they take their sports system serious
he'll just seriously they take it right
Alabama football no they play pranks
ain't Oh some I think was Alabama did
something to the Auburn tree and they
they put some sort of chemical on it
destroyed the tree it was like not to
wear his hair that way though he doesn't
know some dude at soup world brought up
all old school that's when he fought
Washington that's old school picture
yeah that's must be dredged then he tied
him up or something that's a bad idea
Alabama football though you know you
know Auburn's in Alabama as well right I
do I want to ask you something about him
for a sec where does he get his
confidence do you know thing about his
childhood like that do you ever talk
about any of that stuff
I think I'm his child he was just on
below-the-belt podcast this morning
called and he's sick but he know we
really haven't talked about that but you
know he's I think he gets his comedies
thirty-nine I know or yeah thirty-nine
sorry I'm forty forty you know
thirty-nine knockouts and I think he
started I agree it's comments is diff
also to come back like that from Ortiz
and after getting robbed people forget
though he was an Olympian he was like
you don't do drama no that's right right
yeah but into metal and the Olympics
specially in boxing a heavyweight
it's not something you just something
that just have no you're athletic
it's the Duke can fight fight the world
know right in the world yeah if you have
an Olympic medal if you're on the
national team yeah you just don't get
there because you're big
you forget you're beating Cubans you're
beating Russians you're beating schooled
boxers he's doing something right men um
did you find I'm sure you talked about
this but I need to for a second did you
find that there was a bit of a
discrepancy when he had more time to
recover and why did that happen
yeah they asked Dante about and he's
like there's some mishap because I have
nothing to do with that he goes okay
it's conspiracy well what happened in
the you know in the the eighth round the
nights around the 10th round when I was
whooping his ass we conspiracy there
that nothing to do and how much time 10
seconds yeah yeah this we seen is how
much time was it barely enough time then
also at the same time he had you know
rounds after that to beat me did he do
it so I don't consider he was that's
what losers do he was champions don't
make excuses
yeah he was I've had some off nights I
don't make excuses he's never lost
because I've had some off nights that's
when he dropped me in the whatever the
fifth or seventh seventh he goes I have
no excuse that's it that's a good point
that's the way champions act yes yes yes
sir busy week for me ah I don't know if
you want to give me my birthday gift now
or wait a minute hold on 24th close 18
your birthday is the 18th Sunday you
little cutie I'm gonna pinch your little
cheekers be 35 what are you doing I'm on
the back that he lets me off think about
it [ __ ] big man you're mine I know
I'm on the back nine yeah like for a guy
your size 35 is 50 yeah like I'm around
17 little sketchy for me like my family
and friends like I don't know man I
don't know I brain a probably go my
knees I'm ready having issues my left
knee my next step is [ __ ] but sleep on
the floor which isn't helping but yeah
I'm on the back nine though if you think
about it 35 is a rocking but yeah I'm
I'm in my golden years right uh-huh
after this all oh you're in the glowing
years glowing I think it's the glowing
not the golden now golden is later on
it's not a feed go and raisins they're
my favorite and I say the golden years I
don't like the black years all right man
no racist you just said I don't like
black people
no no I do the black years which means
like a dark line
here's his [ __ ] coat for our black
people 35 right now I'm flying high and
then it's just yeah can happen all of us
now I want you to get me a what are you
having a party because we haven't even
gone to dinner for my party we haven't
gone and you have done anything no so
what do you want to do I don't know you
doing something Sunday nope have no
plans should we do something I think we
should you haven't seen the new crib I
got a shitload of elk burger that Rogen
gave me why don't we make elk burger
that's a good idea for real yeah oh shut
the [ __ ] up to my kid to be sleeping
upstairs yeah it's alright that's a
threat my dad this weekend he woke my
kid up I said dad I'm cool with
everything and you're my dad something I
can't disrespect you very much son up
again now put this hands on and and
you're gonna get a hotel you know
Hardesty I'm gonna put these hands on
yeah a few hotel man you can't stay with
me that's the golden rule put poop Jim
Jim wake up little hands on you I have
to sleep on the floor with him I like
that I like the way you say that I like
you saying I put my hands on Amazon you
know you say that the wrong way and
catch a case salt brother that's Jack me
too so I'd be careful I say it too
yeah I'll be right Anthony though been a
cool way you know in the way they got
the Starbucks wait a min like shove me
around what gives what definite shove
means it's called giving it giving you a
shove around
yeah it's shove around new rub pole no I
know I'm sorry I know I know
no a shove around was my birthday like
in a small room and you shoved me again
we rolled up I might get off yeah and
I'm like knuckle deep in your ass I
don't want any of that I'm not saying
that I'm saying just a good old song
what you're saying no I'll just get like
no I want you to get your shoulders no
you get your shovers on we rock we're
fully clear that I'm like stopping
you're like gay and I go bow and I bump
against the wall and it like saw challah
birthday no I don't want the lights off
birthday cake I'm not into you man
you're not for you you're not Adam rip
and he's five seven with a [ __ ] just
a big doe eyes and a beautiful mountain
either you're 51 and gay or not but I
love Adam Ripa take Elaine if you want
this dick make out with that guy because
he's so feminine mmm
and he's funny and he's nice okay
reducing co2 vent you talked about this
a little bit already but you didn't talk
about it here the OJ Simpson confessed
him to murder out here well Brennan
watch this thing so he has more details
on everything I was so into it to my two
takers that I post this on Instagram my
two takeaways are you see just how dark
Oh Jay Simpson is and how much of a
sociopath he is as well I can't believe
says he got out before so he could be
stripe confesses to the murders well i
straight-up confesses to the murder and
then at the end goes this is all
hypothetical though but he talks about
how he exited after the murders how the
murders happen what went down but what
was it was he being theatrical was he
saying no he's under double jeopardy so
he doesn't matter they can't try them
for the murders I mean why any and this
is all hypothetical but it's all then
they had an expert panel on there like
that's some believable the chapter
chapter six is called the night in
question and you write in the book now
picture this and keep in mind that this
is why don't you tell me what might have
happened on the night of June 12 1994
you know have details like justice
hypothetical first wise this is very
difficult for me to do this it was very
difficult for me because it's
hypothetical I know and I accept the
fact that people are gonna feel whatever
were they gonna fit you know they gonna
you know some whatever whatever they
want to fill in the book the
hypothetical is Charlie Charlie this
Carlita made-up gang up the guy where we
still become friends what and I don't
know why you'd been buying the Cole's
house but it told me you wouldn't
believe what's going on over there and
and I've never thinking what I was going
over that's got to stop right so we
hooked up together and you know I'm kind
of broad spoken this we go over get in
the Bronco and go over it let's just go
back and do the details where did you
learn through the detail you parked very
weird this is already very weird Oh Park
in the alley it's two hours long it's
the darkest she's everything you put on
so he's saying this is all hypothetical
but he's talking about it like you use
all the details - why would you do that
that was very strange you reached under
the seat for a knife I always kept a
knife in that car for the crazies and
stuff cos you can't travel with a gun
and I remember Charlie saying he ain't
bringing that and I didn't write but I
believe he took it Charlie took the
knife still in the book yeah okay so
this is the darkest thing you've ever
seen did he do this when was this in
2006 but when he wrote that book to make
money if I did it the publishing house
fight did the publishing house took that
book down because the Brett the Browns
in Nicole Brown's family golden the
Goldmans
didn't want him to make money benefit
off the murders so they actually pulled
the book so and it pulled this interview
yeah but in this area as it goes on you
realize how much of a psycho he is and
how and that so were they able to throw
the book when he gets when he cuz they
is elite in court they said he couldn't
make money off the kiosk so in the in
the murders when he gets the Marin part
he goes the and these are details where
hypothetically he's telling he's
literally confessing he goes you know I
went there because
they were invited to a dinner I'm sorry
he went to a recital his daughter's
recital and then Nicole Brown was going
to dinner with friends and oh joy he
could go and she's like no so he showed
up at the restaurant too and he goes I
was there with my friends they say I was
stalking I show up there with my friends
which he was he purposely set that up so
he could watch her and then after that
she goes back to the house and the guy
Goldman won gold Ron Goldman who died
she left some classes returned them and
he thought he was there - he's watching
Nicole he's spying on so that even
having sex so that guy came to drop off
the glass good guy hey they don't and
they don't know I don't know the
relationship so I can't come on that but
so they get a verbal argument so then
the co Brown comes out she can hear me
she goes get the [ __ ] out of this is my
place and the guy Goldman gets in a
karate stance I can't start a sad no
Jason sue goes what are you gonna do you
kicked my ass and it takes the knife out
and stab him in the face for x and then
grabs Nicole and the hits are on top the
head with the knife and then you know
it's graphic than stats are like four
times takes a head that's what they
think happened
no that's what they know for sure that's
the forensic file that's what they know
100% happens so Goldman got in a karate
and so then that's why that's what oj
says and then they go so what happened
after I just I just went I just it's
just all turned red oh this is all
talking about for this chair so here so
with someone note oj goes they go so
what happened with the murder she was i
never having the knife i remember him
knuckle on top of the head and then i
remember Gomi Gomi on a stance and i
said where didn't kick my ass in the
google and what happened next years i
just kind of blacked out when i'll read
from there and i remember waking coming
to and there's just more blood than he
can imagine i was covered in blood
talk any talk about how he got how he
escaped he was an i ran through two
tennis courts to get to my house i get
there and he talked about how he left on
a plane and how he got the call when he
did with the clothes and it since it's a
straight up confession and then what's
crazy is when he goes I just went I just
I just went red I just went black well
they had the prosecution on there in the
detectives when they talked about the
murder scene it's like no no
what he did was psychotic man though
he'd go back and forth
having them like it was overkill the
things he would do was crazy it's the
darkest [ __ ] ever man oh man we
definitely know if I'm feeling was
wondering worried if he did or not we
does he live in it move down to Florida
is that what they said I forgot where he
moved suits the tragic amount of fun
he's supposed to be in Florida trying to
get him out of Florida know who the the
communal is and the comedian Florida
that's kind of tough to write like what
I don't know what's he supposed to do
you know I heard it he's always
surrounded by a lot of women to this day
like he's this huge celebrity still do
you think still hell yes they love him
[ __ ] yeah he's dangerous he's OJ Simpson
regardless he's one of the most famous
people in the world those people get
laid
there are a lot of women that like the
boogeyman that's a fact near Vegas well
anyway for the forces of nature what
else you got Jen some dark [ __ ] yeah
there's a lot of dark stuff Putin he
admitted that he actually gave the okay
to shoot down a passenger plane this is
in 2014 because they had some sort of
Intel saying that the plane was being
hijacked and headed for the Sochi
Olympics oh right so he he had this
phone call he said all right we'll go go
according to plan plan was if something
like that happens you shoot down plane
passenger plane that makes don't let it
yeah 400 episodes deep cell phone still
going off um but yeah five seven minutes
later they got a call saying oh no it's
a mistake he was just a drunk guy on the
plane Jesus so he actually has made the
call to shoot down the plane but that's
what you have to do right yeah
Boone's got some Botox huh yeah it's
just 100 shirt had some I was surgery
done left face
that's really interesting looks like
Donatella Versace huh I was literally
just thinking please don't kill me I
know he's deaf that some work done don't
kill me
huh he's Chinese yeah that's crazy
though man but yeah yeah I mean I've
seen planes headed to kill more
civilians you gotta get take him out but
I mean that kind of Intel is just
terrible
yeah man oh just a drunk guy don't kill
him you had to be shut down and no cell
wanted you watch him my kinda
what's-her-name from Fox
Megan Kelly Billy Halleck I interviewed
him like you're not smart he is like a
[ __ ] straight-up gangster and she's
trying to catch him and stuff and he's
just going like this is like he's like
did we did we change the election from
all the way over here to do we have our
agencies I don't know who did I can care
less
it's like stop blaming the fact that
Trump won on me and he's right like
here's the [ __ ] that the news they as
long as the news see most Americans want
more money and they have $500 in the
[ __ ] bank and if the news is gonna
keep distracting when you when the news
goes stormy Daniels Russia what happens
is people go you distract any guy and
I'm counting on him to make my life
better
yeah so you guys talking about him
getting laid [ __ ] we don't want money
[ __ ] I want the economy to be better and
all you guys are doing is trying to
[ __ ] distract him and actually trying
to hurt him from doing his job for me I
actually think a lot of people in
liberal press doesn't get I think a lot
of people would give him a kind of just
like I if he's gonna be a cowboy and do
all this crazy [ __ ] great but if the
economy is rocking rise up [ __ ] here's a
[ __ ] yeah I don't care I don't care how
many girls yes is he doing what with the
economy and people have more money just
like I don't care when Bill Clinton's
dick suck in the White House I don't
give a [ __ ]
I really don't man we're obsessed with
this [ __ ] and now stormy Daniels is
suing him and it's a you know look do
this after let him do his [ __ ] job
but also if you're gonna do it shows the
video of stormy Daniels I make money but
we have this economy boom let's see
talking what else get Jen more footage
of that Navy plane stuff
aliens UFOs yeah so this came out
recently check this wattage out it is
above the Atlantic Ocean do daily Bravo
sending this no this is the same thing
the same guys Tom your lawns you know
they thought it was dust on the optics
Ivan if she was just like that so check
it out
you can see that little here it comes
here see you flying by
they're still trying to track it and
lock it down yes I have that on my
nighttime camera there they got it there
[Music]
well it's definitely a piece of dust
they don't fly like now now where's it
going it's just going straight right
above the ocean could it not be a bird
no I think it's a bird what that was
just it could be easily a bird but don't
you know the the the intelligence of the
Navy they don't you think they would
know if there's a bird there's so much
smart enough but also can you get a
better [ __ ] like picture I was a
pretty good one though right I believe
there's life out there somewhere but
that might be a toll bridge maybe maybe
what else you get you a horse this is in
Miami a nightclub in Miami so it was
their idea to have a bikini clad woman
on a horse going into a huge crowd of
people yeah and obviously the horse is
gonna freak out I'm just gonna have some
timepiece in a thong
oh [ __ ] the horse a horse is bucking off
the girl dude huge get on a horse but
does the horse trample people too no
luckily it didn't what is terrible idea
man
but yeah that Club lost their business
license but they a lot rule T hell yeah
they lost their lights what [ __ ]
morons decided to do that what's this I
don't know
I said poppy choking oh no no I don't
see no it's okay they please save the
puppy Oh
so whenever this happens you guys if
your dog is choking you give the dog the
Heimlich maneuver do you know that
yeah he's all top of the mountain no no
no no no cuz their dere Airways pet
stock so if there's a ball stock I did
this I saved my dog's life if there's a
boss stuck in the dog's throat you do
you do the Heimlich on the dog exactly
lower than under there under the rib
cage and just pull up and that's how
you'll save a dog or you can reach way
and look at a poor girl crying out you
can reach way in there middle of your
dog
I watched my dog die in the [ __ ]
kitchen floor and I got him I got him
out and then my buddy bluey they knew
his nose or you can reach into the mouth
together oh that's a pups but you see so
I tried to reach in the mouth to things
small right
I couldn't it's too slippery and it's
too lodged in there so that's the first
things secondly when we got the ball out
when I given Heimlich he had also thrown
she had also thrown up food behind it so
the food from her stomach was blocked so
you have to dig the food out too and
then you give them then you grab their
snout and you blow into their nose mmm I
approve of and my buddy did that until
my dog came to save my dog's that what
else yet you see how I'm with you one at
a time talk about that Rashad Evans
fight so he's returning to
light-heavyweight and he's facing
Anthony Smith that's Andy Smith to try
that light every weight - yeah I don't
see right he was 85 er mm-hmm I love
Rashad men
oh good buddy for a long time I just
feel like it's time to stop it's just
time to stop man he's 38 so y'all know
it's not yes
no no it's always funny when people say
that he's not young rides over the rides
over man it's over and you just stay in
there and it's just
are there any yeah so he's lost four
straight and six of his past eight his
last win came in 2013 against Chael
Sonnen yeah Wow 2013 they wrote that
jeez he's the whole family so silver was
still killing it a 38 I think and then
he got hurt oh no then you saw that came
along Brian big difference you can kill
it 38 if you're on the supplement right
name another sport where you're 38 in
your competitive go oh I should like a
real sport not a skill yeah football
stuff though no not baseball because
they're bat speed speeds up because of
steroids but do you think about what 38
year olds are just out there slinging it
killing it I mean yet time crazy at 38
your [ __ ] body
you just can't at 38 it sounds young it
certain sport you can do but in fighting
and MMA it's just an action time and
speed so much goes into it if you've
been do it for a long time especially at
38 yet years and years and years of wear
and tear on your body yeah so you can't
even train as hard as you
and I will say this to it and it this is
one of the downfalls of our sport is you
know if Rashad was as famous and
successful in the NFL or MBA as he was
in the UFC he wouldn't need to fight he
would've retired five years ago yeah but
these guys you know [ __ ] Chuck Liddell's
trying to fight in Bellator again if if
Chuck Liddell was you know Joe Montana
Tom Brady the equivalent what he was in
the UFC in the NFL you're set for life
yeah but the of course Rashad have to
take these fights and I know anything
about Rashad's financial background I'm
just saying there's a reason why they're
fighting and it ain't because the love
of the game so it's you have 38 to shame
in yeah it sucks what else you got those
was Randy Couture like he's just it's
just a once-in-a-lifetime kind of guy or
do ya exactly no Randy Couture was like
the Cal Ripken of our sport you know
yeah he was he's definitely older he got
a late start and he also had the
world-class wrestling background and he
started fighting
you know old who's already probably more
thing yeah yeah Randy Randy
but he took testosterone did that that
was known that was a sanction by the USA
yeah I remember you know
TRT different time do a different a
little bit different time I think now
guys are striking more and it yeah you
know it's a different animal said
natural know when about testosterone
replacement yeah I got that click on
that I the natural way yeah I've never
heard of him being on it be I don't
think he's admitted to being on it
frankly I remember Frank Mir the big was
Jail obviously Nate Marquardt yep and
even Todd Todd Duffee was on it two feet
doorbell for mm-hmm
but everybody but most people that would
be everybody
we can talk around the issue yeah but
don't Kaplan America don't you dare do
that he never get was alright no I heard
he said something about that or we have
lower doses over tea or tea with our
buddies - etana workouts that athletes
testosterone probably crazy people do it
than we do yes our community is 47 yeah
alright yeah I don't know well says he
has his own experience with charity and
may have a slightly different take on it
and those taken about it in regards to
going to a doctor getting a prescription
so he did it there are other natural
ways through supplementation to increase
your body's own suction testosterone
okay you still want to have it monitor
with a doctor to stay so maybe I heard
him talking about that and that's why I
was thinking that he would be your
outlier that he's your Bernard Hopkins
of the UFC yeah well I got this so we're
just talking about this yesterday I know
yesterday last week how some woman was
giving melatonin to little kids
this is a different story though this
one's like from last year at the 21
years she had 21 years to go to tanning
salon in CrossFit she would leave four
hours that the kids were like leave the
kids alone six months to four years old
alone hours did you [ __ ] what a piece
of [ __ ] did she did and this has come
from a guy with a two-year-old does she
deserve 21 years though intelligence -
so she yes they had the kids some kids
have like like some sort of head
injuries that they found out the kids
got hurt probably were like you know
just running around and doing whatever
they're being two-year-old and
four-year-old and then some of the milk
that she made was too hot so it burned
some of the kids was a terrible person
she did you know what but I mean 21
years just sounds if it was your kid
you'd want to I think they looked at all
of it and she was addressing his kids
for hours and that can be dangerous to
children so I think when you really look
at it this this this makes I agree she
ought she has a mental issue she's also
a sociopath yeah I have some serious
issues she lied to she lied about being
a nurse that's how the parents trusted
her so she she was just terrible
yeah so you think using Hofstra and
Cromley public records guide and see
which least verified didn't you'd go
there for naps hundred hours four of the
charges related to the prior ensign what
did she think was gonna happen what did
she think was gonna happen it's a legend
she burned a babe with scalding milk but
on another occasion 11 of 11 month old
was taking in the hospital with head
injuries but this stuff can be accidents
that's that's that's I'm not worried
about I mean of course I'm worried about
it but well I just the fact that you're
leaving them alone for hours I come four
months six months right you're drugging
them with melatonin oh this [ __ ]
deserves a dime you can't do that now
forget her
what a terrible blow away man that's a
long time ago you know what good doing
that to all those kids men and people
are trust me good and you didn't think
you weren't gonna get caught Todd what
if she's very self you imagine if she
had her own kids how much she's very
selfish unless she's me a prisoner so
she can of her kids thank God yeah mmm
Jesus Christ man
let me see you ever want to see
something good play you never really
want to see someone that's her go down
you wear this picture yeah I do remember
that picture what a dummy
she's a crossfitter no she's a
psychopath you know I CrossFit I
shouldn't chameleon competing CrossFit
yeah but if she did compete I think she
should be freed well not only seeing
anybody good again I don't like see
that's just out of anybody I do gonna do
that to kids [ __ ] up kids imagine if
they do it to your kids no I get it
Matt imagine imagine if little Finn was
concussed yet is yet you know you've got
to get that girl 21 years well here's a
long time it's a long time you know I
could see 10 21 it's tough how old is
she I don't know yeah I'll check it out
24 yeah she'd be lost
we're never gonna win that CrossFit
title and that's the bad thing mmm 21
years at 4-2 Shizuo she's definitely
gonna sing about the other [ __ ] she
probably did so she get out when she's
around 50 and that's it's game over
after that
game over it's it's really bad your
whole life their life's over
yeah you change your name like you were
10 years but 21 I definitely give her 10
between ones a little strict I think
said to man I really do think it's a
yeah right yeah I mean well you know it
she gets it and put her in jail but by
the way even five years is a long time
nah Warriors fives too short you learn
enough well nobody was no kid was
actually technically hurt um and I don't
think but again you're an idiot for
doing that you're a [ __ ] we're a bad
person is it possible that she's an
idiot no not a bad nurse no not 32 yeah
but but some people are just idiots well
she she had your druggies you had the
smarts to give kids drugs okay never
have the villain in her to know when to
come back to leave well also these were
infants and you're giving them 6 1 Kolbe
run you've been around 6 months old and
you think they're leaving them on their
own and if I left my six-month-old in
here it'd be [ __ ] trouble yeah six
months old four months eve said almost a
six-yard men Wow I don't know that's a
tough one man finally comes the kids
[ __ ] that girl enjoy that [ __ ] I don't
forget John nothing much other than
other than Tim McGraw my hero claps
that's your heroes he's my favorite
country artist for sure rich your
favorite song of his don't take the girl
take a great song I never heard it oh
man so good guys your terrorist hit
their little kids at first when they
little boy the little boy sees a girl in
the nail a it forms late for we're gonna
get like in trouble for playing the song
though but you know I'll just chop it up
girl but it's just like a little kid
that with a girl next door you know when
you're a little kid you don't want to be
around girls so his dad's like she's got
to come along with us he's a handsome
song me Tim McGraw yeah
hey this how about it G I'll show you
the lyrics seeking well let me you know
late and then edit it
hmm enjoy this be
you shredded up your seen his workout
regimen I was watching Oh Jim fishin so
let's really see the story take my best
friend bow surprised you know the song
breath yeah I like country music from
Denver Sun song is about a pedophile do
you know that I don't think so yeah I
think you're missing the whole point
you're missing the point don't take and
Sabbat Jim hold on ten years down the
road though no it's the same hold on oh
no a mom is worried yeah door I'll edit
all this stuff out on
I like today tell a story uh-huh you see
where it's gone right and then he shot
her the girl anyway I'll let it be a
mystery the ending what happened because
of that I'm like bro you got to fight
back there so yeah take any girl in the
world he's just trying to take your girl
your team did Tim McGraw's bodied up
these days he was bigger before he was
like now yeah it was big not just in
shady tall guy or is he a short guy
probably like six feet you know just say
six foot six one stud they show him on
tour man he's just doing work he runs
the stadium but with arenas before he
performs or even felt like a brick
[ __ ] well that's him when he's
leaner but he was damaged before yeah
she when guys he's my age right with the
guys older yeah that's I think him no no
that's not sounding good body that's him
with the sledgehammer there that's him
on tour yeah that's that's - that you're
a little too old to be that oscul
super-ripped right there also that's not
natural but your Mac use a better body
than you know I don't that just that's
how old is he
I'm gonna check right now I thought he
was older though you can always tell
it's like a guy a woman who gets plastic
surgery if you're gonna be that muscular
at that oh oh
he said take my wallet take my girl
just don't touch her mouth he's a he's
born in 1965 ten five Tim you know his
dad's professional baseball player named
tug oh wow all right so he's got good
genes he's got good athletic genes and
definite some TRT so he's built like a
[ __ ] though you can't say brick
[ __ ] that wouldn't be a brick
[ __ ]
Brent he's skinny as [ __ ] he's got he's
shredded though he's built for MMA you
should do MMA he should you he's your
favorite chin that's your hero that's
probably my favorite country artist yeah
take my best friend Bo [ __ ] up due to
Bo if you think one named Tim McGraw who
are those guys right there with the
[ __ ] puka shells his dad's name was
tug mcgraw who's that guy with the tits
which one guy yeah Billy Currington let
me see that [ __ ] guy with this
oh he's timid up there that's the first
of all you shave your chest to stop it
second of all you tits what are you for
hey hey hey bro what are you doing if
you want to piss Brian off go to Florida
Georgia line what are you [ __ ] doing
bro take my best friend vanity on men
that annoys me would one doing what's
one the letter line I don't give a [ __ ]
about either one on the right he's just
chillin man who's that guy yeah the one
the rights all right he's kind of just a
big guy I'll shave your [ __ ] chest on
shape on the left you're too old [ __ ]
off
if someone offed you like ever you'd 100
said dude I sure as [ __ ] wouldn't
guarantee you'll never shave in my
goddamn chest let me yeah yeah but let
me ask you this
I've seen it cut you're here I don't
you're talking about yours thank you
check with your own is that it chin
that's it man take my best friend Bo
Florida Georgia line to the floor cuz
they'll get ready to [ __ ] your pants oh
yeah these guys yeah okay bro they're my
favor I know I got you I got you with
your leather tank top and your [ __ ]
leather vest
they hate a what though they make some
tunes I bet they do they got dog tags
and they got it's all
listen man they're probably great guys I
probably get along with them just can't
hang out with you know you could I bet
they rock it I'm sure they do all these
people that is funny you can make fun of
people then you meet them they're like I
you're cool [ __ ] or you not look at
Nellie I can't believe now he's that
short I thought it was always so tiny
Oh fine weird anyway well that's it
anymore that's it that's it that's it
sir what you guys - uh [ __ ]
all right now I'm in Oxnard this weekend
bro good for you I'm gonna karate Friday
so you either come see me and Brendan
I'm coming to see him and then yeah I'm
gonna come see you and Friday and
Saturday Oxnard this week Friday
Saturday night Late Show st. Patty's Day
B Day weekend come out in the force
Oxnard or anywhere around that
California Oxnard levity live Friday
Saturday the next week I'm in Tampa on
Thursday the early show sold out so we
had another show Thursday Tampa Friday
Saturday Palm Beach Friday and Saturday
and then Sunday Orlando and the
following week I'm in San Jose Thursday
Friday Saturday San Jose
improv get your tickets now tea fat cake
Brian tell we're gonna be after visual
time and Alabama they try covering up
April 12 13 14 West Palm Beach April
what is it I'm in Denver
Tommy works comedy works you're welcome
I grant you access to my state yeah he
welcome home wait let me just see where
I'm at just to make sure everything is
good good I'm pretty sure I know where
the like Sebastian said you'd taken a
dip so you can say how good you're doing
no it was like oh no April 19 20 21 I'm
at laughs Boston I'm in Boston gotta buy
my ticket and then April 26 27 28 I'm in
Denver so come see me may 5th Colusa
casino oh I love Colusa man I was just
there it's a girl dude so much to do out
there you have a grand old time though I
am so oh in the room the best acoustics
also below the belt episode 2 this week
[ __ ] where else you gonna be is that it
that's a party
cool man good to see you pal good to see
you little cutie pie we got to do
something this week for your birthday
and mine yeah let's do that for real
alright guys for tickets for Brian
myself TV at kake.com as usual this is
the final kid we're out